two armies on the streets of Beijing the
first works during the day made up of
battalions of gardeners carpenters and
electricians busily preparing for the
70th anniversary of the founding of the
People's Republic of China I have seen
all the great changes in the past 20
years in Beijing people's living
standard has been improved a lot
so this celebration means a lot to me as
well as to many other people I hope that
our country becomes more and more
prosperous we are no longer afraid of
the military threat from other countries
that's why I fully support this military
parade
the second army marches by night when
China's military and thousands of
flag-waving students practice tightly
choreographed displays by daylight the
route a long long peace Avenue and
through Tiananmen Square isn't as busy
as usual many businesses nearby have
been ordered to closed until after the
celebrations large numbers of people
have been told to leave Beijing and
return to their hometowns October the
first is expected to be a demonstration
of China's military might as well as its
confidence in the future under President
Xi Jingping but there are protests in
Hong Kong against Chinese rule there are
allegations being made involving human
rights and of course there's the trade
war with the United States but some
analysts believe the biggest problem
that China is going to be facing in the
coming years is its own economy China's
made significant efforts to open up
trade particularly to foreign investors
but experts warn there aren't enough
private businesses to generate
innovation and create jobs they say the
government of Xi Jingping is increasing
its domination of China's economy what
we've seen since she took power is he's
an authoritarian I mean he's in
authoritarian like bad again like Putin
I mean they won't come from very
different backgrounds but their instinct
is to centralize China's government says
it's determined to keep it society
stable it keeps a tight grip on the
media and the Internet it discourages
comment and criticism particularly from
foreigners on topics it regards as
sensitive or simply China's own business
anyone cannot really understand China if
he or she adopts a very ossified
perspective or is very eager to put a
label on China because China's changing
so many of the misinterpretation or
misunderstanding is probably because of
lack of understanding of the rapid
changes in China China may be changing
rapidly but preventing its economy from
stagnating could become its greatest
challenge Rob Mathison al Jazeera
Beijing